hi
I'm Kevin
let's talk about vsauce2
when I first started making Vsauce
videos Michael and I were each making
different shows for both Vsauce and
vsauce2 resource Kevin here in the 11
years since I started doing vsauce2
full-time I've developed a dozen formats
across hundreds of videos that have been
viewed three quarters of a billion times
the truth is that the the old YouTube is
gone
everything is different now and I just
feel like making my style of educational
content sustainably is
impossible
so this channel as you know it is done
it's just time that I do
I don't know
something else
please bring back mind blowing why did
you quit mind blowing will there ever be
another mind can we get more mind my mom
used to inspire please make another
mindfulness
hey
Kevin
bring back mine below
a coward
Hey Kevin bring back mind blow
do it
bring back mind blow mind blow please
listen
everyone
for the last time
I am not bringing back mind blow
you are vsauce2 was built on the
backbone of a show highlighting the
latest in science news robotics
experimental technology and amazing
inventions some things that seemed
futuristic at the time like wireless
charging or digital face filters are now
completely commonplace other things like
invisibility skin were still waiting on
it was called mind blow I loved that
show and it's been five years since the
last episode I even did a podcast about
why I stopped but every day I receive
comments from you asking to bring back
mind blow so here it is the bring back
buying blow project you will produce
brand new episodes of mind blow starting
right now your involvement in the bring
back mind blow project will directly
support hiring Emmy award-winning
science writer Scott Frank say hi Scott
hi Scott as well as hiring a dedicated
researcher video editor thumbnail artist
fact Checker media manager and all the
aspects of properly returning mind blow
to vsauce2 I'm even gonna end every
episode with the old school NES
cartridge squeeze Vsauce 2 Logo your
role as producer will include submitting
story ideas voting on thumbnails
engaging in great discussions about
science news and seeing your name
credited for bringing back mind blow
because mind blow is your show the
number of episodes every month is up to
you we'll start with one with your
support we can make it too and if things
get really crazy I've got ideas for that
not only will patrons receive exclusive
bonus mind blow content but I have a way
bigger announcement than that the first
mind blow episode in five years is
already done and it's available to watch
right now exclusively to patrons this
episode will never be uploaded publicly
to YouTube it's just for you so if you
want to watch it you have to become part
of the bring back mind blow project
after that every new episode will be
uploaded for free to YouTube thanks
entirely to those of you who join the
project so now is the time for you to
become part of bringing back mind blow
go to patreon.com vsauce2 or click the
link in the description I will still be
doing long form Deep dive videos there
are a lot of topics I want to
investigate but you are returning mind
blow to this channel too some of you
grew up with mind blow some of you now
have kids old enough to watch mind blow
with you and yeah YouTube has changed
but with your help we can do science
news right again forget the content
farms and every other problem with
YouTube we're we're going back to Our
Roots reject modernity return to
tradition and become a producer for mind
blow patreon.com vsauce2 this is mind
blow you are mind blown join the bring
back mind blow project
now
[Music]